I wanted to tell you a little bit about
universals restoration program and a
little bit about this film and as part
of our Universal Centennial in 2012
celebration we announced an expanded
effort to restore the universal film
library since then we have fully
restored 50 titles which includes some
of our classics All Quiet on the Western
Front the birds buck privates Dracula
and Frankenstein at Africa the sting
pillow talk to kill a mockingbird Touch
of Evil Double Indemnity Holiday Inn and
Spartacus just name a few in 2015 we
announced our silent film initiative
which was to restore some of the world's
most classic silent films such as the
last warning outside the law Oh dr.
sensation seekers and many more that
we're working on Universal is committed
to restoring even more films in the
years to come we are in constant
conversation with film archives
festivals and scholars from around the
world there are certain films that come
up all the time
tonight's film is one of those films
king of jazz is special for a number of
reasons at its heart the film is a
lavish musical showcase for Paul
Whiteman and his orchestra in universals
history this is one of the biggest
productions of the time and they're in
an Academy Award for best art direction
the film introduces a 27 year old Bing
Crosby in one of his first feature film
roles king of jazz is also one of those
surviving to color Technicolor films in
the world the film was first released in
1930 and then re-released as a shorter
version in 1933 our goal was to restored
the original version 1930 which ran 105
minutes we started with the soundtrack
negative from the universal vaults that
matched the 105 minute version this
soundtrack served as our template to
which we can form
and four different picture elements used
for the restoration about 60% of the
picture came from the original
Technicolor to color negative that was
held by Universal we undertook a
worldwide search for the elements to
fill in the missing picture most of the
remaining 40% of the picture comes from
vintage 35 millimeter prints that were
held by the Cohan film collection and
the Packard humanities Institute at the
UCLA film and television archive one
hard-to-find sketch was discovered on a
print that was obtained from the Danish
Film Institute in order to retain such
as much of the sound as possible any
remaining shots that we're missing came
from stills that came from our Universal
archives Group one of the film once the
film was digitally scanned and the
structure of the restoration was locked
univer Universal restoration team
performed color correction dirt removal
scratch repair and image stabilization
working in a high resolution 4k workflow
in addition the digital audio
restoration was conducted using both the
1930 and the 1933 nitrate optical
soundtrack negatives both picture and
sound restoration work was performed at
NBC Universal Studio Post which is our
internal facility on the universal lot
in addition to using our in-house
restoration team we also consulted with
experts in the field David Pierce and
James Layton and because every
restoration is a collaborative effort
we'd also like to recognize ycm labs
sonarak & Prasad who also assisted with
film evaluation scanning and recombining
them some of the images and finally I
would like thank Randy and the academy
for hosting the West Coast premiere of
the restoration of the king of jazz we
all hope that you enjoy it thank you